as a shy little girl a daughter of
immigrant parents animated films
introduced me to worlds beyond my home
in my classroom then as I got older I
began to realize that those films
contain some of the most sophisticated
storytelling in all of cinema their
impact is extraordinary and I can't wait
to introduce my daughter to this world
now knowing it will take her imagination
and directions that no one's even
dreamed up yet let's take a look at this
year's nominees for best animated
feature film How to Train Your Dragon
the hidden world Dean Dubois
Bradford Lewis and Bonnie Arnold I lost
my body
Jeremy Pepin and Mark DuPont abuse Klaus
Sergio Pablo's Genco Gotoh and Marissa
Roman missing link Chris Butler Ariane
sutnar and Travis Knight
toy story for Josh Cooley mark Nelson
and Jonas Rivera and the Oscar goes to
Toy Story for
[Applause]
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for mark Nielsen the first Oscar and
second nomination for Josh kool-aid
the second Oscar and third nomination
for Jonas Rivera
[Laughter]
[Music]
we are we are so so grateful for this
honor we just went on behalf of our
incredible cast and our crew up at Pixar
Animation Studios we just want to thank
the Academy for honoring our film
alongside so many beautiful animated
films this year we're just proud to be
among them now we take great pride in
the fact that we get to make family
films and Toy Story 4 is really a love
letter to our families this is for our
parents is for our wives this is for
kids we love you we want to thank the
movie-going audience so much especially
those that grew up with Toy Story
we hope that your adventures with Woody
and Buzz made growing up a little bit
easier my wife I love you so much
[Applause]